each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
okay so being relatively new to this
community it seemed to me there were two
things that I could talk about one of
which is to look at what end user
programming can tell us from a usability
perspective about how to design our
tools how to improve our tools and then
the second is the the thing which is
essentially the more theoretic research
agenda of what can an attitude of end
user programming tell us about living
systems if we apply this as a conceptual
framework what could we learn now it
seems to me that throughout this there's
been a quite a bit of talk about
usability some of which has been in some
cases a bit of a counsel of despair
people have been finding it difficult to
improve the usability of their tools
it's been a frustrating experience for
them so consequently I'll probably
stress slightly more the first half than
the second half than I would have
expected so this is a discussion of how
can we use the usability framework tools
that we have designed to help build
scientific tools that are that don't
exhibit the problems we heard about
earlier of a thousand different users
tell us a thousand different things so
firstly I'll take a brief look at what
end user programming is as a topic then
how can we use it to support scientists
and then conclude with the theoretical
contributions so if we look at the
history of human-computer interaction
and how it's been believed we should
improve the usability of computer-based
systems it has generally taken an
attitude of migrating from the nineteen
sixties approach where everyone who used
the computer was a programmer by
necessity to the approach now called
direct manipulation so this is you grab
objects you do stuff to the objects
literally so you move icons around one
at the time you type and get an instant
response
and mainstream usability has been
migrating computers from here to here
and there are very good cognitive
reasons for doing this the the theories
behind direct manipulation are believed
to be inspired by kind of fundamental
cognition what humans find it easy to do
however there is a trade-off in power
and flexibility when we do this so the
actions on object paradigm whilst it's
proved to be useful for doing things
like writing Microsoft Word leads us to
difficulties when it simply isn't
possible to do the actions on the object
one at a time so there might be a couple
of cases where this might be true the
first is when we want to provide actions
on a lot of objects all at once we've
been hearing about petabyte datasets
you're not going to be dragging those
one node of the time the second thing
that we might want to do in line with
the talk we just heard is when we're
providing functionality that will be
used when I'm not here so we don't want
a kind of infinite army of nomes saying
oh I've got this request I'll drag this
piece of text here here we want to
provide a functional behavior that will
be used at our request these are to some
degree the kind of things which
programming is made up of as a
conceptual activity and they're very
familiar operations to professional
programmers so end user programming
situates itself as an agenda by saying
well we've got a lot of usability
benefits out of direct manipulation but
in exchange we've lost a lot of power
and flexibility we've kind of created
two classes of user the user who can
program and the user who can't this is
unfortunate it's probably not necessary
we can probably improve certain types of
tools by attempting to give end-users
the power they would get by being able
to program back again and essentially
one of the arguments i'm going to make
here is that the reason we are having
difficulty building usable scientific
tools is because sigh
tific tools are fundamentally
programming there is nothing we can do
to escape this so if we consider them as
direct manipulation tools suddenly none
of our techniques into work and it's
because they're designed to solve a
different type of problem so the first
thing to note is that end users can
program there is nothing to say that
somebody who doesn't have a degree in
computer science has difficulty
programming we have the numbers are
difficult to estimate because the
various complexities but we have two to
three orders of magnitude more people
who write software in exile in the USA
than we do who are classified
professional programmers so we have a
few million users using this most of
them will never have read a manual and
yet they can do so this is good news
similarly the powerpoint animation
functions you can make a square migrate
to another square along a path when i
click a button without having to do the
operations one at the time this is an
example of programming in our world the
programming language is here okay it
looks a bit different to see sharp but
some of the conceptual activities are
still the same and okay so powerpoints
functions get abused but the Kothi there
is nothing there is no cognitive barrier
preventing people being able to do this
and likewise I believe one of the talks
later is about mashups this is yahoo's
tool for building mashups rapidly
combining functionality from various
different websites and again we have
end-users enthusiast's creating systems
like this and it seems reasonably usable
and it's not even knew so this is a
visual programming language from the 80s
that found it some of the research in
this area it's known as LabVIEW and you
would see professionals not computer
scientists engaging in building this
kind of program sharing them with each
other and using them to diagnose tools
diagnose problems and if you follow this
through you can see similar things to
their superior in things like MATLAB
Simulink so the point of this is that
end users can program there is nothing
fund
for stopping them we just need to give
them the right tools and understand what
the right problem is okay so the next
question might be then well if everyone
can do this why does it need a name it
the point I'm trying to make here is
that by calling it end user programming
I'm not just attempting to engage in
some form of academic land grab it's
that there is a fundamental recognition
that the cognitive activities a
programmer is going through is different
to the cognitive activities of the
operations on objects it's a more
abstract task by definition and because
it's a more abstract ask a lot of our
techniques that were designed to remove
abstractions from systems in order to
make them easier breakdown so if we take
this which is part of the security
configuration interface of Windows if we
look at this through the standard lens
of a direct manipulation user interface
approach it looks reasonably good so it
has rapid feedback it has operations on
objects however if we look at this
through the lens of a programming
activity it has severe problems so it
has for reasons that I'm not going to go
into particularly much it has very
strong hidden dependencies I can create
cycles which I can't see here these
cycles have important usability
properties and it has / provision ality
I can't make approximate marks and then
tidy them up later we know this is
important for the way programmers work
it has poor progressive evaluation if
I'm trying to complete a large complex
task then I can't do it in little bits
and understand how far I'm getting
through the problem so we have two
issues the standard tools that we've
been trying to use run into all sorts of
problems predicting things that should
be good when the tools if we look at it
like a programming language predict
problems and indeed in user studies we
see the problems occurring so by
understanding something that something
is programming the idea is we can make
it substantially more we can apply
different techniques
which helped the usability in different
ways so three techniques cognitive
dimensions of notations which is the
most accepted 1 i'll be giving a two
minute overview of the attention
investment framework which is a
discussion of when people begin
programming and when they choose to
switch from one cognitive behavior to
another and how to support them during
that switch and one in progress which is
the user experience of intentional
information so how do people perceive
the intention behind programs that won't
be covered at all so and user
programming for life scientists what we
did is if we take this kind of thing
which is the kind of tool we are
building and which is a description of a
regulatory network model in this case in
the custom c-sharp application then we
use the analytical tools of NGS
programming we consider this to be a
behavior like programming and apply them
and compare in this case the version
before the improvement and the version
after the improvement slightly biased
description it was an improvement we get
good provisional results by applying
these tools so the point here is that
end user programming techniques have
been shown to be relevant to improving
the usability of the tools we are
building so cognitive dimensions this is
probably slightly miss targeted for this
audience the idea is that we consider a
user interface as an environment so if
you look at word the the text in the
middle of it the document is the
notation the things surrounding it are
the environment and we consider an
activity of these along various
dimensions which we know have cognitive
properties so one of which is a question
of how diffuse the information is so for
a long time it seemed that visual
programming languages should solve all
of our problems I mean that can you just
connect stuff together and it works but
yet textual programming languages like
we saw are still dominant as the main
way of programming the argument for why
this would might be the case perhaps
might be that visual programming
language
far more diffused to express the same
thing so if we have a complex problem we
need a lot more space that means it
becomes difficult to see connections
across things etc this causes problems
we have viscosity so if I perform one
change in my labview diagram suddenly I
have to change everything that was
connected to it everything that was laid
out around it this is a standard problem
how many abstractions are the within the
system that I have to learn etc etc so
this gives us a way of talking about the
various usability properties of a
programming language and how we can
structure the programming language to
support those properties or to choose
trade-offs between them and we end up
with analytical results that look like
this where to a first approximation the
volume of red shows a concentration of
serious problem in that area so we
should be concentrating usability
resource on these issues and okay they
may make some bets slightly worse but we
can afford that that will result in an
overall improvement to the usability of
the tool we are building so this is an
argument that essentially if you're
going to use one of these tools
cognitive dimensions may be one of your
best shots at improving the usability of
it unfortunately the typical training
time for it we've managed to get it down
to about three hours worth of training
plus a small demo so I'm not going to be
able to kind of explain how to do it
here and now but this is perhaps an area
that might help us get out of the
problems that we've been talking about
throughout this conference and it the
tool is showing a dot the the cognitive
dimensions are showing adoption it's
been successful in tight scientific
tools Microsoft use it very heavily
improving the usability of api's it's
shown the ability to talk sensibly about
security usability it's shown
improvements to spreadsheet design okay
so there's some value here if we take
that and if we take this attitude that
we're talking about of what does end
user programming mean for life
scientists and take it a bit further
so Jasmine Fisher's work is the
collaborator on this paper has been
saying what happens if we consider
biological processes like C elegans to
actually be instantiations of
computational processes then what we can
do is have an interaction between a
computer model of something and the
biological process so we build a model
we compare predictions from the model to
actual real wet lab data and use this to
either suggest new experiments that we
might do so discovering exciting new
timing properties of living systems has
been one of these things or we may use
it to observe that the model needs
adjusting and this provides new
theoretical understanding so this
technique of looking at life in this way
has given us a number of successes so we
have experimentally own we've
experimentally verified some changes in
the regulatory models that otherwise
might have been too expensive to do by
just experimental approaches so looking
at one of these refinement pathways
takes a lot of hours in the lab by
looking at it in a software lab first we
can more appropriately spend this
expensive lap time we have jasmine and
her collaborators have proposed new
concurrency models to better reflect
what we believe is happening inside
biological processes and formal methods
have been used for what we believe is a
relatively novel technique of proving
that models of data models of biological
systems verify against data that's been
experimentally taken so this gives us
some sense of completeness and assurance
in the totality of the model as opposed
to single point verifications along the
way so this seems very promising there
are a number of challenges one of which
is that computer systems don't tolerate
ambiguity very well there is a lot of
ambiguity in regulatory
that works to do with their timing
behavior it's unclear in many cases how
to do practical experiments that can
obtain the kind of timing data we would
need in order to understand what those
arcs mean so that's one thing that's
difficult with the biology a thing
that's difficult with the computing is
that the computational models
programming languages as we know them
today are generally designed for doing
useful things making computers do stuff
that doesn't necessarily mean they have
particularly good fit to biological
processes so we are in the in need of
new abstractions the abstraction
processes that we have today of saying
here's this chunk of stuff I'm going to
attempt to build a black box around it
and pretend I don't need to look inside
it don't really work in terms of
biological systems if you tend if you
look in more detail they tend to break
down they tend to break down through
complex context interactions etc so we
need abstractions where we can look
inside the abstraction when we want to
essentially a scalable level of detail
as opposed to a stair casing level of
detail and in studies of professional
programmers we see that abstraction has
subs has fully severe problem in actual
programming computers as well in using
biology so if we could get a more
sensible way of talking about what
abstraction is in computing we would
improve both sides of this balance then
there is the more fundamental question
of what does it actually mean to
consider life to be a program we can we
understand programs with the goal in
mind we understand them to change some
behavior it's not clear to me that that
is what would be desired in
understanding life as a program so we
have also seen I was very happy to see
Barker being quoted earlier today one of
his contributions with a Jeff star to
the philosophy of knowledge is
understanding the classification systems
don't merely observe the world they
changed the world so the International
classification of disease is a complex
ontology for representing
how people got ill how they died and
using this for forming government
statistics so it needs the consistency
that we've heard about frequently here
this also means that different types of
information got recorded so it changed
our understanding of for example the
wake heart disease gets recorded in the
Far East it has a social stigma attached
to it so if it's reported only to the
government if you get separate reporting
to the family into the government you
tend to get different answers than if
you get single reporting to both so when
we create this abstraction the way in
which those abstractions are going to be
used has a substantial effect on one
gets understood out of the end of the
system so if we are designing
abstractions with which to do science we
should be careful about how to what we
want to understand and how we're going
to shape our knowledge afterwards so how
to introduce that into the process of
building abstractions that are also
computationally tractable is one of the
kind of key research areas we're looking
at and and ultimately adoption of these
tools and therefore impact into the
scientific community is not purely a
technical matter we need to once we've
decided to some degree what questions
are interesting and how we're going to
produce answers to those questions it's
important to understand whether the
community also thinks those questions
are interesting fundamentally if they
don't this will the tool will not gain
adoption no sensible new knowledge or
understanding will be generated so what
I have said usability is crucial to
adoption I don't think that there's very
much need to go on talking about that
given previous speakers the standard
techniques for improving direct
manipulation systems are necessary but
they're not sufficient for dealing with
problems were fundamentally the
cognitive activities programming this is
not as bad as it seems to be there are
user programming techniques used to
understand how people own how to design
programming languages to improve their
usability how to do
sighing complex systems to improve their
usability for end users with lo with lo
technical training in in programming for
example there are techniques out there
that can help executable biology takes
the process of saying what happens if we
consider living systems to be programs
it's essentially a pragmatic form of
computational ism this results in deep
challenges such as what is it we are
trying to understand how can we shape
the design of the programming languages
to give us that understanding we seek
and this process of designing new
abstractions to support that goal
hopefully will help both computational
biology and computer science programming
activities in the wild so to speak so
hopefully accelerating discovery by
providing new ways of thinking about
biological systems time for questions or
shall I wrap yeah so we have three
minutes for questions just reminder if
you have questions please walked with a
microphone
so given the criticism of visual program
programming language by people like
bonding RT brad myers why did you choose
to use a visual programming language for
your investigation if not a more control
of language so the criticism by the
criticism by brad myers for example
which I know more about is not a blanket
criticism what he's reacting to is the
kind of the euphoria or visual
programming the belief that it will
solve everything so indeed his student
and eco is one of the leaders in visual
programming language as the field so we
chose to use a visual programming
language because it provides things like
the relatively gentle slope of how much
of how you can learn the abstractions
throughout the process which textual
languages struggle to provide so its
usability property is aligned to the
kind of problem we're solving what I
think Brad and bonnie was saying is they
don't solve every problem for free and
certainly I agree this is a very
interesting talk in general and programy
people are also talking about
programming a large and the programming
is small and you might believe you know
visual program is really more for into
the paradigm of programming a large
because programming a small D centuries
like C C sharp or Java focus on the
functionality on the other hand
programming in large assuming each
building block already developer using
traditional language and the folks on
the coordination of communication
between that language so can you comment
on the relationship between these and
the usability or the programming partner
you talking about
so that's a very interesting question
it's not entirely clear to me what the
how well the parallel from programming
and the large to biological systems for
example right now the the workflow
committed in particular Center will flow
most of the legs you and right now
actually visual sure its programming the
latch yes I understand to some degree
our biological systems look like
programming in the large in the sense of
they are single blocks encompassing
quite a lot of behavior within the block
and the behavior is it a fairly abstract
level of description and what we're
interested in doing to some degree is
understanding the emergent effects of
interactions between them so to some
extent that looks like the kind of thing
we do with workflow programming in the
large on the other hand part of the need
for translucent abstractions is that
only looking at things in this large
level of granularity and detail proves
insufficient at times so we need the
ability to take apart these large blocks
and move towards perhaps more textual
representations so far we haven't done
so badly with basically grade based
representations which underlie the
abstract blocks you would have seen on
the screen so the distinction is
interesting and becomes particularly
interesting when you look at things like
the techniques that for example
Microsoft or Google would use to manage
the running of a large compute cluster
where everything starts to behave
non-deterministic li and you need to
overlay controls over the top that has a
lot of correspondences to the kind of
problem we try and solve an executable
biology and I think it's fair to say
that we don't really know the usability
properties of the languages we need to
support that yet so that's kind of
ongoing work
so we'll have last question please make
it quick do you or how do you
distinguish between simulation of say
cellular biochemistry and executable
programming
that's a very good question Jasmine who
runs the executable biology group views
this as a very important distinction
that one requires one essentially
executable biology and carries to some
degree a commitment to how it should be
executed within the program itself
whereas simulations how it should be
executed independent I'm I'm less
inclined to view this as a kind of
important distinction and would see all
programming as a son part simulation
some part execution really dependent on
kind of how much intention would we
ascribe to the things so if we're
talking about arks up-regulating and
down-regulating that's a kind of
intentional mode of description
certainly a kind of a gentech mode of
description that's where I would view
the difference be so being essentially
in the kind of language that we would
use to describe what's going on if we
were talking to another person about it